son visage est l'emblème du cercil
depuis 30 ans celui d'aline koren majeur
assassinés à auschwitz le jour de ses
trois ans sa photo et pour la première
fois exposé avec celle de son père
abraham un survivant au serre si l'on
peut désormais découvrir cette autre
trace de leur passer un message d'adieu
retrouvé par hasard dans une baratte à
beaune la rolande en 2013 ce à quoi
personne ne s'attendait c'est quand
débarrassant l'intérieur de cette
baraque soit découvert un graffiti un
kadhafi ti à la craie bleue donc quelque
chose de très fragile où on peut lire
koren bajer emma aline le 6 août 1942 en
souvenir pour ceux qui passeront ici et
ma c'est donc la merde aline ces objets
et ses photos évoquent l'immense travail
de collecte menée par le cercil ces
trente dernières années
des morceaux de vie qui témoignent d'un
passé encore douloureux pour de
nombreuses familles
pour vous donner un exemple de recherche
celle qu'elle peut pas revenir
observe-t-il
il s'agit par exemple ici d'une personne
qui demande à faire des recherches pour
un ami qui lui n'a jamais véritablement
osé ou réussi à explorer son enfance il
sait que sa mère est partie et elle
n'est pas revenue
hélas le ctrc le rôle du cercil c'est
justement à partir d'un nom parfois il
ya plus parfois il y a un nom une date
il y à une photographie et à partir de
ce moment-là de mener l'enquêté
l'exposition sortir de l'oubli revient
aussi sur la naissance du cercil en 1991
a paru à l'époque comme une nécessité
la nécessité de regarder l'histoire bien
en face pour que les leçons du passé ne
soient pas oubliés
où